Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Since the latest explosion in AI research,
virtually no field of science remains untouched
by neural networks.
These are amazing tools that help us solve
problems where the solutions are easy to identify,
but difficult to explain.
For instance, we all know a backflip when
we see one, but mathematically defining all
the required forces, rotations and torque
is much more challenging.
Neural networks excel at these kinds of tasks,
provided that we can supply them a large number
of training samples.
If we peek inside these neural networks, we'll
see more and more layers and more and more
neurons within these layers as years go by.
The final decision depends on what neurons
are being activated by our inputs.
They are highly efficient, however, trying
to understand how a decision is being made
by these networks is going to be a fruitless
endeavor.
This is especially troublesome when the network
gives us a wrong answer that we, without having
access to any sort of explanation, may erroneously
accept without proper consideration.
This piece of work is about distillation,
which means that we take a neural network
and try to express its inner workings in the
form of a decision tree.
Decision trees take into consideration a series
of variables and provide a clear roadmap towards
a decision based on them.
For instance, they are useful in using the
age and amount of free time of people to try
to guess whether they are likely to play video
games, or deciding who should get a loan from
the bank based on their age, occupation and
income.
Yeah!
This sounds great!
However, the main issue is that decision trees
are not good substitutes for neural networks.
The theory says that we have a generalization
versus interpretability tradeoff situation,
which means that trees that provide us good
decisions overfit the training data and generalize
poorly, and the ones that are easy to interpret
are inaccurate.
So in order to break out of this tradeoff
situation, a key idea of this piece of work
is to ask the neural network to build a decision
tree by taking an input dataset for training,
trying to generate more training data that
follows the same properties, and feed all
this to the decision tree.
Here are some results for the classical problem
of identifying digits in the MNIST dataset.
As each decision is meant to cut the number
of output options in half, it shows really
well that we can very effectively perform
the classification in only 4 decisions from
a given input.
And not only that, but it also shows what
it is looking for.
For instance, here, we can see that the final
decision before we conclude whether the input
number is a 3 or 8, it looks for the presence
of a tiny area that joins the ends of the
3 to make an 8.
A different visualization of the Connect4
game dataset reveals that the neural network
quickly tries to distinguish two types of
strategies: one where the players start playing
on the inner, and one with the outer region
of the board.
It is shown that these trees perform better
than traditional decision trees.
What's more, they are only slightly worse
than the corresponding neural networks, but
can explain their decisions much more clearly
and are also faster.
In summary, the rate of progress in machine
learning research is truly insane these days,
and I and am all for papers that try to provide
us a greater understanding of what is happening
under the hood.
I am loving this idea in particular.
We had an earlier episode on how to supercharge
these decision trees via tree boosting.
If you are interested in learning more about
it, the link is available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!